on today's show we talked to a wife
whose husband is coming back from being
deployed and she wants to know how they
can reconnect when he gets home
we talked to a dad who just got out of
jail who's working through sobriety who
wants to be involved in the life of his
young son
and we talked to an awesome licensed
social worker
who challenges me on my thoughts on
alternative schools stay tuned
hey what's up good folks this is dr john
dolone welcome
to the dr john dolone show i just called
myself dr
john and the first person that annoys me
to no end when someone refers to
themselves as
hello hi i'm doc don't my name is john
that's what my mom named me
and it's been just fine for my entire
life so
my name is john this is the dr john
dolone show and that's because i didn't
get to name it
by the way and on this show i take calls
about your life your mental health we
talk about
everything right schooling educational
concerns parenting addiction
marriage everything life love loss life
love loss that sounds like one of those
things that you put on a board in
somebody's kitchen next to like
gather and i don't know it's a
geez louise every karen who listens to
this just cheered
and everyone else just went oh gosh and
all the cairns don't send me cards and
letters i didn't mean that i meant that
metaphorically
sort of but i love karen's but i love my
wife the most
listen listen thank you for joining us
today on this podcast
we have been off for a while and you can
tell that i am not on my a game but i'm
just leveling up right now
we're going full deloney on this one
it's going to be good i want to start
the show this way
um actually first let's do that no i'm
going to do it this way i'm going to
start the show this way with this letter
because it
really got me choked up and i'm not a
chokey up kind of guy that's a lie
every time i watch a movie i got choked
up i got choked up at like
some kid movie pets 2 or something
yesterday
i am a chokey up kind of guy but i like
to say it out loud i'm not a chokey up
kind of guy
i got to my desk today and there is a
book
and a note here a handwritten note from
germany
and it's from gary james holland gary
james holland i hope you're not
um in the witness protection program
because i just put you on blast but the
reality is nobody's listening to this
anyway
so gary james holland sends me a book
and if you're watching this on youtube
you can see it
it is an original copy of viktor
frankl's man search for meaning
in german and here's what he writes
dear dr dolony he can say it because
he's not mean it's not weird
dear dr in sincere appreciation of your
work
i feel compelled to give you this book
even if i fear you may have no practical
use for it with it being in german
well played fair enough you'll know the
book by the title of its english
translation
man's search for meaning by viktor
frankl as i'm sure you'll know being a
leading mental health professional dr
frankel was a psychologist of austral
austrian jewish ethnicity who wrote
about his own experience of nazi
concentration camps from a personal and
professional perspective
the german title actually translates as
say yes to life in spite of it all
but man search for meaning rings better
in english right
dude say yes to life in spite of it all
it just stopped me i've had a hard like
my family's been having some stuff we
just having some challenges
um the ice and the snow all those things
and i know i i dated the show here but
this will come out several weeks after
it's just been a mess man
and that phrase say yes to life in spite
of it all
and and gary james holland goes on to
write like uh
several pages about his family and just
how much the show means to him so gary
i just want to thank you dude from the
bottom of my heart this will be a prized
possession of mine i have a small box of
what i call my prized possessions that
i'm going to make sure my kids know you
don't throw these away you don't sell
the stuff you hang on to these
and this is going to go in it this is
one of my favorite books of all time the
english version
and i'm super grateful that you reached
out that you told me about your family
that you told me about the successes
y'all are having that you appreciate the
podcast
and more importantly you wrote me a
handwritten note and gave me this gift i
just want to thank you so much
for everybody out there if this show
challenges you if
you think i think that's i don't agree
with that at all you can do two things
you can call into the show and we'll get
you on because i love having discussions
like i said i used to work in college
all the time and i loved the debates and
the back and forth from people who are
all trying to search for truth not
people who are trying to
hate on each other um or you can just dm
me
and say you suck and i hate you one
feels good and it gets you on your day
one actually solves problems so if you
don't like things on the show or if you
think i disagree
call into the show i'd love to have you
on and love to discuss it on the air
that'd be great
and if the show means something to you
if you're getting someone out of the
podcast if you and your family you're
starting to do things a little bit
differently if you are starting to walk
a little taller if you've decided to go
to counseling
if you have decided to reach out to your
husband or your wife in a way you never
have or
you have been dating someone forever and
you realize this is not right
you know what i mean i'm worth more than
this if you are making changes in how
you eat and take care of your body
man reach out and let us know i'd love
to have you on the show
i'd love to give you a shout out and
just tell the world
how proud i am of you how excited i am
of you and
more importantly these things lift me up
man and if they lift me up i hope they
lift you up too so
gary james holland you rule thank you so
much everybody else give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's
go to 1-844-693-3291 show fill out the
form
and we will check it out and see we can
get you on the show we're getting
emails and calls from all over planet
earth now it's good times
all right let's go straight to the
phones today let's go to alana
in colorado springs alana what's going
on how are we doing
i'm good how are you doing i'm doing so
good how is
everything in the colorado springs area
oh it's lovely no complaints here
it's so gorgeous one of my best friends
on planet earth my friend craig lives
there and
man every time i visit it's i get
jealous it's just such a stunning place
very cool very lucky so what's up how
can i help
um so i am looking for ways to reconnect
with my husband
um and i've heard you speak um on past
episodes about
taking retreats annually with your wife
um
so sort of do inventory and discuss your
marriage and i was interested in
learning more about that
very cool so um tell me about your
husband
um so he is in the military and um
he will be returning from deployment at
some point in the next
um in the near future and um
i love how you did that like he'll next
week late soon
eventually at some point one day that
was
that was such a i'm not even gonna say
anything well well done that was awesome
if you work with military families or
you are a military family you are
laughing to yourself right now if you're
not
just recognize they live in limbo and
these poor spouses who are at home
are carrying a lot a lot of stuff on
their shoulders and so
um we're grateful for you alana okay so
he's coming back at some point and go
ahead i cut you off
um yeah so we've been married for eight
years um
we have a five-year-old and a
two-year-old so on top of just the
physical separation
you know we've been spending the last
five years um
with a bunch of crazy people in our
house um
keeping us awake and yelling so um i
think just with the
um i work also so we both have pretty
high stress jobs
and i think the most difficult part of
deployment is
when they come home and trying to
reintegrate because
over several months you really change
who you are as a person you have
new experiences and you don't get to
share them in real time
with your spouse and so um it really we
had a a pretty hard time last time you
came home
tell me about that tell me about the
hard time um so i
was um a full-time student and doing an
internship
um my son was two and i was pregnant
um and he was gone for several months he
came back
a week before my due date um so we had
integration
plus a new baby um and so
it was um and we have part of the issue
is that we have very different parenting
styles okay
um so that's a big source of conflict
for us and we um
between his last coming home from his
last deployment and when he
left last year we've really been working
on
um that together and um trying to
we've we've made a lot of progress but
it still is
it's a source of of worry just for me
um and yeah and just
i i feel like we kind of don't we
we live together we cohabitate but we've
just lost
some of the like button parts with being
married yeah yeah
so um you've got a couple
you got a a double or even triple whammy
here and so i want to pull it apart a
little bit
not give it the full and we could do a
whole show on this and maybe we will
someday
um an entire show dedicated to veterans
and their spouses
and leaving and coming back and even
just the day-to-day stuff the identity
stuff
all of that wrapping its self up into
this little package called marriage and
what have we been doing together right
um but today i want to pull a couple of
pieces apart number one
you know this but i just want to
reiterate if your husband was the most
high functioning connected at home
all the time and he was just an
accountant having two little kids
in your house is just shake it just
everything changes
right and so you put that sort of
deployment on top of i mean that's
sort of a turn on top of that you put
all of the
political stuff all of the safety stuff
all of the identity stuff
all that goes into this big thing but it
underlies
man your house was already right already
just like a snow globe that somebody
shook up
and so what i want to to encourage you
to do this time
the best you can it's going to be hard
the best you can
is to both of you but you can only
control you right
to to be open about doing this one new
and not bringing any of what happened
last time not bringing any of the we hey
we had these fights it was crazy let's
start completely fresh here
okay and you may have to write stuff
down you may have to be intentional
about i'm nervous he's going to be
coming home in two weeks or one week and
last time he got home and he didn't
sleep and he was loud or whatever his
challenges were
reintegrating um and so when he gets
back is he gonna
is he getting out or is he gonna stay in
is he gonna have a job on a base here
yeah he he will have a job when he gets
back um oh he's staying in
okay standing so his identity will still
be he'd still be military right he's not
gonna have to also
that's a whole other shift from military
to civilian okay
so here here's a couple of things you
said you've been working on your
parenting styles they're different is it
fair to say you both
love your kids you just love them
the picture of what love looks like is
different for both of you and you're
trying to merge that picture is that
fair
absolutely okay so when you say you're
scared or nervous that word picks my
like it peaks my interest what are you
scared or nervous about
is he a yeller and you're a hugger is he
one
there to have four corners when they
make their bed and you just don't really
care about like
what are you nervous or scared about
yeah i would say
that's that's pretty much it um we both
know that we fall on opposite ends of
the spectrum
um and so he's very positive about it
like
balance each other out um but it's still
i it's yeah it's still a challenge for
me
and i think part of it too is letting go
of um
being the parent um solo for nine months
and letting him parent again that's
that's also a challenge
yeah so here's a couple of things i want
to challenge you guys too
number one i want you to start
and this is gonna sound cheesy i want
you to start dating again long distance
okay and what you're gonna what i want
y'all to focus on
is you're going to build a totally new
marriage you're going to build something
you've already got some great
foundations to it you've got a history
to get you've got almost a decade
together right
you got two kids but i want you to build
a new adventure together
and look at that as an opportunity not
as a chore
okay it could be super exciting but i
want you all to start
dating again and start intentionally
being flirtatious start intentionally
being like what could this look like not
what is it gonna be does that make sense
and it sounds tiny and you hear those
those analogies where somebody's driving
and if you just turn the wheel one
degree you end up turning all the way
around
was it what book was i reading recently
maybe it was james clear's book that
says
the the take off from if you're at lax
and you're going to go to washington dc
or you're going to
well maybe it was boston the difference
in it was seven
feet that's how different that no the
nose angle that plane is to get you from
oh it's new york city to washington dc
right so i'm talking little bitty things
but
hey i want to imagine what our romantic
life is going to be like i want to
imagine what waking up next to each
other is going to be like i want to go
ahead and let's
could we get not pre-marital counseling
but can we go ahead and set up some
counseling where we can learn how to be
married again and what we're going to be
able to get a common language and
accomplish things together
but you see what i'm saying i want this
to be an exciting awesome moment like a
reset not
a how is he going to fit into our life
does that make sense
yes and the biggest challenge folks have
not the biggest there's a bunch of
challenges reintegrating but one is you
just
nailed it you've got a life right it's
not one that you love you'd love him to
be around
but you got a life of man your kids have
a routine you all do things in a certain
way they come to you for clothes and
laundry you'll have
everything and then you try to figure
out how to shove him into that when he
gets back
that's the cause of so much conflict so
rebuild it from the floor up
the second thing is give me two or three
things that you love about him
oh he is incredibly smart
[Music]
he loves his kids
and he takes really good care of us okay
none of that had to do with
y'all too
[Laughter]
you gave me three different things one
attribute about his cognitive ability
and two performance slash achievement
based things
what do you love about him he makes me
laugh
let me ask this a little more um pg-13
what gets your heart beating again
um he always thinks i'm beautiful
he tells me all the time does he show
you
yes okay and when he says you're
beautiful and he shows you're beautiful
he looks at you across the room in that
way that you know
who that gets your heart beating faster
again
yeah do you miss that
yes are you excited for that to return
when he gets back
i'm very excited yeah okay and i know
that part's hard because you got to shut
that off right
you got to completely turn that off
that's why i want you all to start
dating again
okay and the things that you love about
him i want you to focus on not the
achievement things the things he's going
to bring back
but i want you to focus on him right
and then the third thing is is i really
this sounds so cheesy so here's some
things that we do
on that my wife and i do on our on our
retreats together
is we look in in the past with
that past year the things that have gone
well things have been hard
right this is going to be a little bit
different you don't have to go back if
you don't want to
but you can go back and say hey in the
past this has been tough this has been
tough
i want this to be like this right um and
then we spend some time
on what is this year going to look like
if we could if it could be as perfect as
we wanted what would it look like
what are some savings goals how much do
we want to pay off on our house
how much uh do we want to go trips
together what's our week going to look
like every week like i want to make sure
we're building in times for us to
connect throughout the week and then
we'll let the week fill in on
behind that so depending on what his job
is there um but we
set some here's who we want to be we
want to be we've been
my wife and i've been together gosh 18
or 19 years we want it to be
like we want to make sure we're still
flirty we want to make sure we're still
laughing we had a hilarious food fight
the other night in our house
and right when i drilled my son with
like a
like a half-eaten banana and he threw it
back and it blew up all over me i
watched my wife dude
she like exhaled and i could see it like
cut and then it's almost as though she
remembered oh yeah we're having fun
and then she's like you're cleaning it
up and then she got involved like
so it was those we set those parameters
we want to be folks who are just silly
again right
and he may say i want to have some
higher structure than last time
but what you're doing is you're being
engineers and architects for
the future not complaining and whining
about the past
and not being anxious about it is he
going to fit in our thing you have to
rebuild a whole new thing
and your kids bring them along not for
the romantic part not for the discussion
of who we're going to be as a couple
but bring them along when he gets back i
want you all to
um have a canvas right i should have
brought mine i didn't know we were doing
this but
i have a canvas at our house that we did
with our kids
and it's our family core values like who
are we and
we say yes and we have adventures and we
treat each other with dignity and
respect
and we have uh we are hospitable we
always have
crazy people staying at our house and so
whenever i'm like hey son let's go out
and play in the creek and he's like i
don't know dad i'll say
hey we're adventurous uh stallone's
adventures and he's like okay
that's who we are and then we head out
but inviting the kids into that
to as a part of this rebuilding together
i love it so here's the thing
really focus on him start dating each
other again
go ahead and get somebody go ahead and
get a professional and hope
some military guys aren't into that guy
military guys if you're listening to
this
it's cool man go see somebody to help
you learn a new language this is just a
new set of
skills doesn't mean you're broke and
doesn't mean um you're dysfunctional
it means hey i'm going to pick up some
new tools i've been gone a year i'm
going to help
get some coaching as i re-enter this and
then build
something new together right don't try
to drag the past
forward and see if he can plug into your
existing world now let's rebuild
something new
it's going to be incredible alana i want
to know when he gets back
i want you both to give me a call let me
know how things are going and then we
can check in and see how things are
rocking and rolling and see if i might
be able to help along the way
but the fact that you're calling now
tells me man it's going to be so good
i want to thank your husband for his
service i want to thank you for being a
rock star of a mom holding it down it
there in colorado springs
and i can't wait to hear your story
about y'all getting reconnected it's so
good
all right let's go to jamie in atlanta
georgia jamie what's going on
what's going on dr john just rocking and
rolling brother how can i help
um so i guess we'll dive right in let's
do it now
so about five years ago uh
i was uh i was on drugs really bad
with uh my son's mother um
and uh they were all the fun things
they're not really fun that's that's a
really bad joke
and she uh she was able to quit i was
not i was not able to quit at the time i
couldn't uh i couldn't do it
and so things got progressively where
she left
uh which was the right definitely the
right move to make she left
and uh i was still in georgia and she
left and went back to wisconsin which we
moved
from there to here and i moved from here
to there before all of that
and uh i ended up going to jail several
times
and in one of those times going i was
able to have
what we call the vital spiritual
experience that was enough
to uh to this day i have not found it
necessary to take any mind altering
substance
awesome past three years good for you
man so you're 36 months in
yeah well over that it's september 22nd
2017.
congratulations brother that's a big
deal man um
and uh hold on you have to acknowledge
that that's a big deal
right i appreciate it i appreciate it
thank you okay
all right so
i've done everything i will work out a
big book of alcoholics anonymous and you
know it says in there you know
uh you know we write it on us letter if
they they won't hear us right so i wrote
an honest letter
talked to her multiple times and every
time
um even in the times where she's like
her our uh our son is four now
um and uh i've never seen him i was in
jail when he was born she moved back up
to wisconsin
for good reason i was incredibly abusive
okay um
and uh you know it's just uh
every time she says you know it's always
the same response it's gotten to the
point where it's always the same
responses you've never seen him you're
just a sperm donor
um he has a dad now he doesn't we don't
need you
you're not even a part of his life and
then the last time i sent a letter i
wrote a letter out i had people
proofread it
make sure that i wasn't saying anything
offensive or too selfish or anything
like that
but just you know and you know she
responded back
at first with because i paid child
support
um i'm up to date on child support i
make sure you know
as i'm supposed to because it's the
right thing to do is what i want to do
um and uh you know
uh she said well if you go to court you
know you'll get drug tests but you'll
probably get vegetation that's the best
i can do
and i was about to say like okay or
something then she responds back with
you know how her parents left her
because she was adopted
um and her parents uh never got off
drugs and never came to go see her
and she voiced that to me along with all
the other things too which i have 100
admitted
that that is what it is and i told her i
was like look i will go to a counselor
i will tell them everything that i did
to you every wrong i'll tell everything
that i did to anything else but we gotta
say we gotta do that
that'll be fine and and then all that's
to no avail the closest thing was her
saying to go through the court system so
you know i'm just kind of at an impasse
with it you know i've talked to plenty
of people about it you know and it's
just
so what's what what what is the common
advice you're getting
well um it's actually none of it's
common
to be honest with you it's all different
uh
a lot like my sponsor is like man you
need to just pray about it and let god
work that out you've done the best
you pulled you're into the bargain or
whatever and i i don't feel that that's
sufficient and then i have another
person who says
jim you need to be ready to uh you've
never been a part of this child's life
or anything like that
are you ready and willing to accept it
if you are not allowed to be if this is
not your place
and like i said yes and i guess yes is
the thing but have i explored every
avenue
you know what i mean right is that is
that the really the final answer here is
that
is that i don't i don't i don't you know
um
is it me being selfish i don't know
you know yeah it's something that i
react my brain with all
the time brother listen there's not a
selfish
that's the wrong word when it comes to
your kid right
parents who are selfish with their kids
right if you were still using and that
kid lived with you
if um you were blowing rent
on you know partying with your buddies
or whatever
then that would be selfish wanting to
track down your son
after you've been healed for three years
or you're
you know you'll learn some new ways of
of getting through some of the hard
stuff in life
um seeking forgiveness that's not
selfish that's you chasing your son
okay um so
just in the few things you've told me
your wife um
man she's got demons from when she was a
kid that i don't blame her for a second
for
right she had parents that walked out on
her she's lived that road
who knows the trauma she's carrying on
in her heart and mind i don't blame her
for a second
you said you're abusive tell me about
that um i was both
physically and uh verbally abusive okay
did she ever call the police on you is
that why you went to jail or did you go
to jail for using no
no she she never did i went to jail uh
for using after we had moved down here
and she had left you know she gave me
the ultimatum
you know she told me at one point i
remember uh this is my part of the
supreme sacrifice you know she said uh
you know if you could just quit you know
everything be all right and you know i
made that promise and
30 minutes later it's like it says you
know i couldn't bring in the sufficient
memory the pain of a week or a month ago
and
before i knew it it was already too late
and uh i had
gone back to doing what i had always
done since
since for a long time so why did you get
clean man
uh but at first you know
i was i was sentenced to drug court so i
couldn't leave the state
for the first year and a half two years
um
and i got i just had a guy listen to me
out front of the clubhouse that i stayed
at that was my home group for a long
time and he listened to me
and you know i was just offered it was a
lot of it's god's grace man like i can't
explain it any other way
no no no not how why
why are you clean now because i'm sick
of it man
i just i and i didn't i like and now i
have something that works
you know what i mean like i i 100
believe
that at that point in time i was
powerless and i was a slave
i was an absolute slave to everything
that i was doing i had i had no way
to work through it and nor could i see
if there was a way
right and today you know i've been given
somebody sat down
and worked with me and gave me the power
to take control of my life
and to live by a principles that don't
allow for excuses
and that don't allow for me to go back
to that way okay no matter how hard it
is no matter whether i'm crying on the
floor
wondering why why why or anything like
that like i don't ever have to go back
to that today
and that's so i choose that you know
what i mean wake up in the morning i'm
like oh nope this
is way way better yeah absolutely so
here's the here's the bottom line if i'm
you
and i have my little boy out there i'm
gonna
move heaven and earth try to see my boy
and at this point um
he does have a man who stepped up in his
life i'm assuming she's remarried
now is that fair well we were never
married okay is she married now i
i do not know okay i don't think so but
i don't know
okay um you mentioned she had a dad
in there in his life now yeah her
adoptive parents
uh took care took care of her okay you
know she has she has a very good support
group
did you sign custody over for him i did
while i was in jail
okay um
i man without getting into your
backstory
too deeply and we would need some time
to sit down and go through this
here's what i'm telling you what i would
do um
there are a few things on planet earth
more important to me than my son
and i would move heaven and earth to do
that
there's a part of me that thinks that
your wife
still loves you and cares about you but
you beat her up man
you scared her you left her alone and
that
is that fear it's not even a fear that
meant those memories those experiences
override any feeling she has
and it's at some point it feels like
she's asking you i'm gonna see how far
you're gonna go
right and so what i'm telling you this
may not be the
the most sound legal advice this may not
be the most sound
big book advice okay i'm just telling
you guide a guy what i would do and i've
got a son
a young son myself i would call every
lawyer i could find
i would do whatever i had to do
to be in my son's life i would be
sending my son
probably a weekly letter
so and now you're playing both a short
game and a long game
okay number one at some point you're
going to have this conversation more
than once with your son about
who you used to be and you
want to have a track record where i son
i chased you to the ends of the earth
i wrote you every week i screwed up your
dad was sick your dad was acting
the fool that your dad didn't have the
right tools and who knows what your
trauma is like you may be able to teach
him a lot about what you experienced as
a young guy
right all that to say is that will come
over time so you're playing a long
relational game what you're aiming for
right now
is that when you're 50 and he's whatever
30 35
that y'all are hanging out together that
you get to go see your grandkids
okay you're not you're not shooting for
everything to be rosy and hunky dory
because this four-year-old little boy
has no idea who you are
right and so i want to have a
co i want to constantly be reaching out
to him and his mom is right to protect
him right now
and um but i you can't control what she
does you control what you do so i want
to write a letter to him every week and
mail it to him
and hopefully she'll read it to him and
or heezy gets older he'll read it you
can draw him pictures whatever that's
going to look like for him
the second thing is now i'd be on the
phone with a lawyer tomorrow and say man
i screwed up
i signed over stuff when i was in jail
and i want to go meet my son
and i honestly mean you're talking
between states you're talking i don't
know what your
full criminal history is i don't know
any of that stuff and so i don't know
the legal ramifications how that would
actually get together if you would have
to move to wisconsin to have
i don't know any of that stuff what i'm
telling you what i would do
is whatever i had to do to hold my son
right and then just know it's going to
be a
slow slow process of rebuilding trust
and rebuilding trust and those days are
going to feel agonizingly slow
you're going to have seasons where you
are you weep you're going to have
seasons where
you want to punch a hole in something
and you're going to have to constantly
be practicing those new skills that
you've picked up over the last 37 38
months
right and you're playing a long long
game you're raising a man
and you're both healing and you're
healing one too right at the same time
right all right so tell me why you want
to see your son again man
you know and it's not not again why you
want to see him period
you signed away your name you said he's
better off without me i'm out
why do you want into his life because
even if at that time i mean even if my
thought was he's better off without me
even today even if he has a new dad you
know what i mean like i'm not there to
interject
in between all that that's literally the
last thing i want to do it's not but
if there's ever a time where they can't
do something you know what i mean i'm
not saying i'm not challenging
their capacity to take care of him but
if there's ever a time where it might be
useful
for somebody who has the proper
motivation to
show up when nobody else is over to show
up i can do that i have that motivation
you know i mean i really feel that you
know what i mean like
i don't i know that i messed up
in that sense you know i understand it i
i've worked through it i put it on paper
i see it
you know i own that but you know
it never hurts to have somebody who is
who would drop
everything they're doing if i'm at work
if i gotta fly up there if
there's a hospital thing if they're you
know what i mean if there's a cove bid
listen listen you're giving me a bunch
of things
you're giving me a bunch of tasks you're
giving me a bunch of achievements
a bunch of accomplishments those are all
good and they're all noble
but when somebody asks you hey why do
you want to see your son
i want to hear you say because i love
that kid i've never even met him
because there's a piece of my heart
beating out there somewhere in wisconsin
and i got to meet him i got to know him
and i got to love him
and i gotta make sure that he never goes
to bed at night not knowing
that his daddy loves him
right and those other things that you
mentioned
those are all derivatives of that right
because you love him
because you've got a piece of your heart
beating somewhere else out in the
universe
that's why you're going to show up right
that's why you're going to go see a
lawyer and probably have to work
overtime to pay for that or pick up a
second job to cover that cost
that's why you're gonna have to get in
front of a jury or in front of a judge
and
say the things out loud that you did
right
and you're gonna have to risk being told
by a judge you cannot see your son
right right and that's all a risk and
that's all scary that's all freak out
time right
but all of that is the why is because i
want to see my son
right yeah i want to see my son i love
him
i never have even seen him
and that's going to be what drives you
over the long term and here's the thing
my promise to you brother
let's say the judge says no like i can't
relieve that past i can't put that
trauma back on mom
i don't know that that's the case i
would doubt it but who knows
there will come a day when he comes
looking for whose dad
is there will come a day technology has
gotten to a point where he's going to do
23andme he's going to get on facebook
he's going to figure out who dad is
right and i want there for y'all to
i want there to be a track record like i
said earlier i want there to be
a a bread crumb trail
right back to your heart that said i
wrote you a letter
every week for 14 years before you
turned 18 and were allowed to come see
me
i saved money for your college
and i never even got to see you for 18
years but i knew
that there was going to come a day when
you were gonna come meet me and i wanted
to be able at least you may not wanna
talk to me at all
but i want you to know when all those
burns to the ground
your daddy loved you and your dad was a
wreck and a
mess and a broken guy and i'm healed and
i'm whole
and hey look i've got i'm married now i
got kids whatever your situation is
but son i kept chasing you and i kept
chasing you and i
kept chasing you right
so yeah man um i'm on the phone today
i'm on the phone first thing eight
o'clock tomorrow morning trying to get a
lawyer that i can afford
that's gonna be excellent that's not
gonna go to war with my wife
i mean my my ex right with my son's mom
i'm not going to war i'm not trying to
burn anything down
but i want to find out every option i've
got to go see my son
and here's the thing i want to keep in
in your heart mind
be honest every step of the way i want
to applaud you for your honesty here
for your healing you got to move forward
you did some stuff that was ugly and
despicable and gross i'm not going to
beat you up for it you know
and now it's about putting the bricks
down brother and then running off into
the
into the light right running forward so
man i love your heart jamie go find him
and
go find your son if you are able to
check in with him i want you to give me
a shout back i want to know how that
reunion goes
if you're not able to give me a call
back and we'll walk through what next
right
because these things don't always have a
pot of gold within this rainbow man
sometimes these things do not have a
happy ending so um thank you so much for
your call brother
um all right let's go just take one more
call let's go to emily in dayton ohio
emily what is happening how are you
doing
i am doing awesome how about you i am
rocking on to the break of dawn
so how can i help okay
well i kind of have a different question
than most people um i've been listening
to your show
and really appreciate your perspective
on mental health and mental illness i'm
a licensed social worker
and i find that often times you and i
have the same
um outlook on calls but a few months ago
good that's good that makes me happy you
actually know what you're doing
i don't so that's awesome good no see
you you know what you're doing
um but a few months ago you were talking
to a mom about her child who was
struggling with behaviors at school
and you had made a comment about um
alternative schools and i kind of
picked up a negative connotation to the
comment that you made
um and i just actually recently left my
job working in an alternative school
setting
and it's been haunting my dreams i just
need to know what dr
john deloney thinks about alternative
schools oh you're the best
okay and number one this makes me happy
because i thought my mom
and my little brother was listening to
the show so we've got three listeners
ladies and gentlemen this is awesome
um two tell me about your experience
in an alternative school what was it
like what was it about
okay so and i i realized that every
school's a little bit different
and um i don't have like an opinion
either way
i was fresh into the field when i took
the job
but our school um follows a
trauma-informed care approach
um to the best of its ability emily i
can stop you right there and tell you
yes that's awesome the fact that you can
say the words trauma informs tell me
you have a different program the fact
that you're a licensed clinical social
worker
at an alternative school tells me that
however messy it is
your school district is unique and
different than most in the country
okay but go ahead okay so
we took in um students that their
home district weren't able to meet their
needs okay
um so the particular like they had
different
like programs but mine was primarily
behavioral
disorders or like kids that struggled
with their behavior so
it was unsafe for them to be in their
school district or their school district
couldn't meet their needs
when someone we're talking what i would
call
um pollyanna counseling terms when we
say
the school couldn't meet their needs in
more brash terms the school kicked them
out because they were caused they were
disruptive to the learning environment
is that fair
yes yes yes like most of them had been
suspended expelled or they were working
their way
towards there and you know they have to
educate the student so that
this was their way of educating the
student and so for
the average listener out there the
school has a
the estates have a mandate to that they
pass to the schools that every kid's got
to be educated
and then a kid comes to class and he's
super disruptive or he's got special
needs
and or both and it's or he's got really
tough situations
whatever but it manifests itself in the
classroom that he or she disrupts the
learning environment in some way
that a teacher and or a group of
teachers and or a principal kicks the
kid out
and says you've got to go to a special
campus out of here
um because we can't deal with you right
or as
us super sweet counselors will say um
or i'm not i'm not account so a super
sweet mental health
thinkers will say kiss can't meet their
needs so that's such a kind way to say
that you're so lovely i'm like okay
so you they couldn't meet their needs
and they went and saw you give me
uh what was that environment like so it
was all
small group settings so no more than 10
kids
with a high ratio of adults so at least
two adults in every classroom
everybody had mental health counseling
we had individual
group and there was also occupational
therapists
physical therapists speech language
pathologists
the teachers were you know given lots of
training
in trauma-informed care um and that was
kind of how we operated
um it was really cool what school is
this
man listen
if you took a group of mental health
professionals and put them together and
said
let's create the perfect place you're
describing it
right for the average listener what is
um real
like in 30 seconds what is a
trauma-informed school
so a lot of times when kids are having
behaviors a lot of times something bad
has happened to them
in their life so it's recognizing that
their behavior is trying to tell us
something they're not a bad kid
you know they are they're trying to get
their needs met so they might feel
unsafe
so they might act out or they may
be afraid to build a relationship with
another adult because adults have let
them down in their life so
they're going to push you away because
they don't want to trust you or it's
easier if they damage their
relationship rather than be hurt later
so it's taking that hit all into
consideration when you're approaching
them
we did a lot of teaching the kids how to
do emotional regulation recognize what
we use the zones of regulation which is
i don't know if you know what that is
yes
okay um to kind of recognize like
identify their feelings and then
identify coping
skills so we did a little bit less
education than a traditional school
would do because
you can't educate if you're not
regulated so we we helped
the kids kind of get to a stable so that
they're i don't know emily i don't even
know who you are
i was having a day that was not
great i'm just being honest i'm sorry it
wasn't a great day
and you are restoring my faith in
everything
everything what you just said is so
profound and if
the government of the united states
would listen to that
nobody if you take maslow's hierarchy
right and that little top triangle
self-actualization and right below it
right like
being able to actually process facts
right we expect our citizens we expect
our
kids we expect college kids we expect
people in the workforce who are
exhausted hungry traumatized fried
broke unable to eat
to go in and fill in the blank right be
perfect citizens and learn all this new
information
and you try to tell a 12 year old that
or a 16 year old that who by the way as
you mentioned
again so kind way nicer than i would say
it
um who parents um who adults may have
not lived up to their expert
adults that physically and sexually
injure them
right and then they show up to a class
and we expect them to look in front of
a geography teacher or a algebra teacher
and these schools can turn into failure
factories right
so let's cut to this
when i'm talking about not liking a
alternative centers
here is my challenge with alternative
schools
and i will even go up to um because most
of my behavioral stuff my wife's phd is
curriculum instructions like so she's
worked in k-12 schools i was a high
school teacher
i was a k-5 teacher for a year but most
of my time has been working in student
conduct
in colleges and universities any of
those settings
the idea that when you look at behavior
as in and of itself and then you
are punitive against behavior without
any understanding as to where that
behavior is coming from right
every behavior like you said is a
language it's communicating something
sometimes it's i'm real hungry sometimes
i can't sleep because there's 42 people
in my house every night high
i can't the focus because i'm starving
right
all sorts of i can't focus on this
because i've been abused and
my are sexually assaulted and my brain
will not shut off
fill in the blank fill in the blank fill
in the blank and so anytime a school
who again has to hold up the integrity
of a classroom setting
they use alternative centers punitively
get out
we have to preserve our test scores for
this group of kid
we want you out of here because you're
going to hurt our bottom line score
and they send them to an alternative
center where they put them in front of a
screen for eight hours a day
and they do they just go through the
curriculum alone
or they have automatic triggers right
they've got hey if you have
alcohol you're automatically in um
you're off campus at the alternative
center for
and they all have these cute names too
by the way every school district in the
united states has a fancy cute name for
their alternative school
but we send them away punitively we send
them away
with this like the goal is just to
remove you from our community
and when you are struggling with all of
those different connections
throw in special needs on top of that
right if someone's got processing issues
or learning disabilities or autism on
top of that
you throw all that together and i just
need you out of here so that we can get
back to our calm quiet life
that that mode of thinking dominates the
way schools
operate and i want to also honor the
schools man every school i know is
underfunded every school i know
is being pushed on by parents and by
government leaders they are caught in by
unions that are all over the place just
a mishmash right
what you just described is different it
is
i literally and i was making fun of it
but you're right
i can't meet your needs because you need
more than we can offer
not i'm kicking you out because we don't
love you or not we're kicking you out
because you're loud
you're allowed for some reasons that we
can't help in this setting
so we're going to surround you i wrote
this down ten kids in a class
in a group two adults per class that's a
one to five student ratio
that's magic right and then you're
talking about
trained professionals social workers
counselors speech pathologists
right imagine being a 12 year old many
of you listening can
who got picked on because they had they
weren't able to speak properly
right or not even properly quote unquote
normally or the way that
other 12 year olds aren't just gonna
ridicule you and imagine walking to
class every day and having a teacher
point at you and say stand up tell me
uh answer these questions live and you
know you're gonna get made fun of and
you're getting made fun of you're gonna
make fun of oh by the way your dad makes
fun of the way you talk to
and the fact that you can't pronounce
your these words in the right way
and you're gonna lash out right and what
does your school district do emily
you all went back and actually tried to
teach and educate and give this
kid some skills so that they could
return to that classroom right
what was your recidivism rate i wonder
well so i kind of bounced around grades
and
when i started with the older kids i
will say
it was really difficult to get them back
to their home district for many reasons
um i think the younger kids it was
a little bit easier because
i don't know i feel like once you
there's a double-edged sword right
because then you get kind of stuck in
the cycle
and you know it's scary for them to go
back
or they don't have to do as much work at
this school academically and they like
it so they don't necessarily want to go
back but also like
the school districts care but if they're
smaller
they just don't have what they need
to help those kids so this really is the
best placement for them
right so i definitely think there's a
mix and it really depended on each
case scenario um especially
if you've got kids with high anxiety and
now all they've wanted their whole life
is to go back to their school and
they're trying
but they're anxious so now they're going
to have behaviors because they're so
afraid
of the school setting and they have you
know past
experiences that were negative so it is
kind of hard
to to transition them back but i have
seen it happen
and those cases are are really cool and
really rewarding to see them get to go
back
i can imagine a scenario where
um man what i mean
what kid in the world would want to go
back right
right i finally go to a place where
you're teaching me skills accepted by
your peers and yeah
my teachers look me in the eye no one's
making fun of me there's some guidelines
there's some
yes that's the magic word there's some
connection there right
so um here's the thing
alternative centers for schools i get it
all the way around
i've been a high school teacher and had
to send somebody out dude because the
student was violent in the class i
get that the goal for
a school well you could send me on a
whole other tangent emily about
about testing and all that kind of stuff
um
if my kid leaves k-12
with understanding how to regulate
themselves
how to connect with others socially how
to work hard and solve
problems how to work and navigate
systems
right how to work with different adults
and understand this
adult needs things this way this adult
needs things this way this don't need
things this way
i'll consider that a massive massive win
and if you look at the man i'd love just
to sit down and have a hard conversation
and i could learn some stuff since i'm
not taking this on as a challenge but if
a principal or a superintendent wants to
call into the show too
i would love to have a conversation
about the rise in technology spending
how every kid gets 18 different devices
and we have all these smart boards and
all this
tech and stuff like that and we've got
kids who are struggling socially
we've got kids struggling with some of
these basic services because i don't
know how to self-regulate
i don't know what to do because at my
house it's like this
and when i look at the
family dynamics and the data on families
and i look at the fa
the data on poverty and look at the data
on trauma and the data
data on child abuse it's a direct
link to the the data on
test scores dropping right and
piling more tech on there well you know
what they really need is a chromebook
that'll solve it
now this is a weird year because of
covet so don't write me and be like
chromebooks save the date you're right
they were helpful way to go
but the chromebooks plus the pod the uh
the ipad plus the this
plus the that plus the this is and
that's and
dude what you just have described to me
me emily is a masterpiece does it always
work no is it always going to put every
kid back in a classroom no because some
kids aren't going to ever want to leave
that safety
and that set and that that where they're
finally seen and heard
what i want schools well everyone who's
involved in the idea of
student discipline is to get to
number one what is this behavior trying
to tell me right
if you wait until there's a behavior
issue you've missed it
as an educator i had to go way upstream
right
i've got a buddy who's the
superintendent for years and years and
years he's
extraordinary he used to have to get rid
of kids who were in gangs
but he also would meet with their kid
their parents the leaders of the gangs
in the local community
and with the students like kind of the
student reps of these gangs
and say i want you here but you can't do
these four
things you can't do these five things
otherwise you can't be here you guys are
choosing at that point to opt out of
here
i'm not kicking you out you're choosing
to opt out because you're being violent
because you're picking on people you're
whatever the things are and you get that
type of buy-in on the front end
then downstream some of these things
take care of themselves right we've got
a safe campus we've got a
campus that is supportive we have a
campus that is about
educating not about testing we're about
learning and teaching
not about um this and i know funding is
tied to teaching so i'm not blaming
teachers i'm not even blaming
administrators here the whole thing is a
mess
but there are schools these
trauma-informed schools especially if
you want to read up on something
fascinating these trauma-informed
schools are i think are extraordinary
but like emily just described here where
what can we do to support this
kid how can we help this kid heal from
the inside out
so that they can go into a classroom
into a social setting and then actually
do the hard work of learning geometry
right actually learn the hard work of
coding or of
learning about the civil war and
learning about world war ii et cetera et
cetera
so that when they get to college so then
when they get to the workforce they have
these
behavioral regulation techniques they
know what to do when they get frustrated
they know what to do an adult yells and
screams at him when
a classmate yells at him
emily you have given me hope for life
to every teacher out there i can't i
know
i've been there i've lived with a
teacher i have been
there is no harder job school
administrators i've worked with school
administrators behind closed doors for
years and years and years
there is no harder job
but what emily is describing here and i
also know that the law school districts
are broke
broke but if we were to step back
from the testing we were to step back
from the we got to get all this tech in
there
we had to step back and say how can we
help these kids be whole so that they
can learn
man emily just gave us a road map i love
it i love it i love it i love it
emily thank you so much for that call he
just made my heart feel good
and i was getting frustrated between my
heart feel good all right so as we wrap
up
man hey listen i'm gonna bring him back
i said this was the greatest song of all
time last time
same guy different song he has two of
the greatest songs of all time
figure that one out america this is off
the love ire
and song record by my man frank turner
in 2008 this book on
this book this song is called
photosynthesis and it goes like this
well i guess i should confess that i'm
starting to get old all the latest music
fads have passed me by and left me cold
all the kids are talking slang i won't
pretend to understand all my friends are
getting married and
married in mortgages and pension plans
and it's obvious my angry
adolescent days are done and i'm happy
and i'm settled in the person i've
become
but that doesn't mean i'm settled up and
sitting out the game
time may change a lot but some things
may stay the same and i won't sit down
and i won't shut up and most of all i
won't grow up
maturities are wrapped up package deals
so it seems and ditching teenage fantasy
means ditching all your dreams
all your friends and peers and families
solemnly tell you will have to grow up
and be an
adult and be bored and unfulfilled well
if that's your road then take it
but it's not the road for me america
i'm not telling you to not be grown up
it's frank this is frank but i love this
song
this has been the dr john dolone show
[Music]